all righty buddy we're back another day
in the pandemic Monday you better open
this [ __ ] up I'll tell you that I think
it's they're gonna open it up it won't
be that long I don't think well like I
said man I heard I heard that they're
having problems with like food
production
I saw me yeah I saw an article about
like a pork plant or something like yeah
there's several meat plants and then
like a then they're like certain farms
are just tilling the [ __ ] produce
back into the soil because the demand
isn't there because like schools and
institutions haven't opened it's a sales
of plummeted which yeah the restaurants
and stuff rides they don't need as much
product right and that's that's not good
because if sood production goes under
you know I mean because they're used to
having higher profits in order to
maintain themselves they go under then
that means when things go back to normal
there'll be a lack demand will you know
be stronger than supply so I would I
think they ought to do is either get
everybody out there working again or
they take that food and they send that
food to just distribution centers they
give it out yeah that might be the best
thing you have the government subsidize
it and they pay the government buys the
food well yeah because that would be
kind of like win-win they will still get
the money stored and it wouldn't go to
waste
right and then you could just hand out
free food yeah for people that but that
might have a bad bad result too because
that means that the store prices you
know would start plummeting because now
your grocery stores have to compete
against free foot against well yeah but
I mean the freedom it's really
logistically I mean how many people
would be able to access all the free
food yeah you know what I mean because
they don't have that much yeah I oughta
just you know just take a whole
truckloads of it you know the main and
half places where you can go down there
and get it yeah drive it down through
the damn neighborhoods you know take as
much as you want eggs I'm dealing
they're flush and all kids like just
like the hundreds of thousands of
gallons of fresh milk or just flushing
it demands gone yeah it's like that's
that's something that I guess I kind of
thought about it but then I was like oh
yeah like because a lot of those foods
shishun companies you you know you only
think about other [ __ ] you buy at the
supermarket but yeah they have like
whole plata whole branches supplying
like schools and [ __ ] offices and
yeah [ __ ] like that
oceans and that's not there anymore
because everyone's and it's gonna have
to be there when it opens back up
they're gonna have to what yeah they're
gonna have to like do something and then
they'll have to like slowly ramp it back
up as they because I mean what what
they're probably gonna end up having to
do is just like reopen things in like
stages right so so it's not like a big
they're already they're already saying
that the worst of it's over and that
certain states are gonna be able to open
back up that that will help a lot I
think yeah so then you'd that way look
you know it's gonna be kind of piecemeal
I guess for a while but yeah heavily in
effect the states are gonna be closed
maybe a couple more weeks longer but I
think they're gotten I think they're to
the point now where you know what would
they say that that the cure is worse
than the disease it's just time to go
ahead and just open it up it's it's you
know it wasn't it's nowhere near as bad
as they thought it was gonna be no words
well that's because people actually most
people actually did what they were
supposed to yeah well and you know they
knew a lot of people were gonna get sick
a lot of people are gonna die she didn't
want it all happen at once and I think
that's over now I think they could
probably just let it right I mean shot
is open yeah I heard that they were
trying to reopen yeah that was yeah so I
think I wouldn't surprise me if parts of
Europe to start opening up so I think
it's over well I'm you know we'll see
though like it's probably the worst of
it is over but never did get my check
no I nobody ever seemed to get their
check and I think that [ __ ] got approved
but where the hell is it I don't know
all right well I heard that they were
mail it well if I heard that if you like
filed a 2019 tax return which I did
obviously and you had direct deposit
already set up with the IRS which I'm
pretty sure I did because I mean I
didn't last couple years I haven't got a
refund obviously because I've been
freelancing so I just have to pay but
they have my bank account information so
I was told that I didn't have to do
anything that it would just go in there
automatically and they said that some
people that they were gonna mail them
paper checks but that won't start going
out until May 1st okay that's what I
heard I don't
I don't know if that's correct or not so
please check you know I'm not I'm just
saying that's what I read so I'm not
really sure how accurate that is I don't
think it's gonna last much longer I
think that just according to what
they're saying in public they're worried
about social unrest parts of the country
gonna have to open up yeah just you just
can't keep this closed yeah but as I
said it seems like if there's places out
in if there's places where it's not as
bad or they don't think that you know
health services gonna be overwhelmed or
something yet maybe they can slowly
start yeah opening [ __ ] back up and they
just keep like the the worst places like
in lockdown just so it doesn't spread
any man he'll be able to track it he'll
be able to see and here's the deal
they don't know how lethal the [ __ ] was
because they think most cases were
asymptomatic that means a lot of people
have this medium more than people know
the people that get it don't even know
that they have it well that's why
they're so worried about them like
infecting other people because you might
have it and not know I guarantee you I
guarantee you the infection is far
bigger than they know yeah I think it's
done most of the damage I bet you how
much you want to bet we have it or
already did have it it's possible yeah I
mean we haven't been going out that much
so it's less likely right world this
happened all that sick though that's
true that might have been it I didn't
get it though no but maybe you did but
you didn't notice well there's some
people are saying that probably it's
mostly asymptomatic yeah so you might
have been sick but had no symptoms the
only thing I've had lately is like my
nose running and that's because the
[ __ ] pollen got a [ __ ] damnit yeah
the pollens really bad down here this
year and like I don't have allergies or
nothing it usually doesn't bother me but
it's like holy [ __ ] man it's like the
[ __ ] car is that in the driveway and
it's just like covered with yellow [ __ ]
did we tell him to go cdfw
yeah but well wait yeah we did like I
think we said that yesterday today
yesterday we just we we did like a whole
like review of it but that won't be up
until like Saturday or Sunday if you
guys haven't seen VFW go rent that yeah
just like clean $3.99 off the xbox was
worth every [ __ ] penny yeah it was
like a John Carpenter flick has a child
carpenter
super bloody yeah there's good blowing
off John Carpenter style soundtrack and
everything I thought I was watching a
good John Carpenter movie for me a good
one not a bad job yeah well at least the
ones that John Carpenter made like
Early's were so good yeah that it
completely overshadows ya cuz I think
some people that know like you know the
good John Carpenter movies like the
thing in Halloween and stuff they don't
even know like about the later ones
there haven't even seen them because
some of the later ones I haven't even
like really about ya directors kind of
having a half life if you ask me I mean
they they start off pretty good a lot of
them then want the good ones do and then
I think their hearts get broken and and
they get a little too rich and they're
in this [ __ ] just these half buckets
just a page you know you know who I'm
gonna exception to that those are George
Miller yeah add max yeah true cuz [ __ ]
fury road oh yeah
one of his best movies fuck-ups some
people that's like not not only the best
George Miller movie probably one of the
best movies ever about that movie I mean
how can you not love [ __ ] fear but
after a while after a while most
directors are named in me [ __ ] to me I
mean even James Cameron like dudes if
that dudes were didn't wear [ __ ] anymore
I don't think oh yeah Terminator that's
just [ __ ] sucked
he used to be good but well I think
generally I think in pretty much any art
form there's like a this isn't true of
everybody obviously but yeah it's
usually when they're younger yeah and
you got some to prove and then you know
then it's good and then it's kind of
like a slow decline not always cuz
there's some that like still make bad a
[ __ ] like when they're old but it's
rarer rock you know what I mean I feel
like if you your best [ __ ] is probably
when you're young and you're dumb yeah
okay then maybe novelist so I feel like
people that write books sometimes their
earlier books are not as good as the
later ones hmm not with Stephen King
that I feeling although I hadn't read a
lot of his new ones I think the last one
I read of his was under the dome maybe
which is several years ago he's probably
written 40,000 books by them that I
haven't got to know in that [ __ ]
although you know Ridley Scott was
consist
we good I thought there yeah well movie
said I really weren't interested in he
did like some war type movies and [ __ ]
whatever but you know black rain and
alien and Prometheus and all that you
know he's always doing something
interesting like even if it's a genre
that you're not super into like it
seemed like an interesting yeah he's
still like an interval into like yeah
he's like an auteur yeah you know what I
mean now you got older you could tell he
spent a lot of time drinking but you
know hey I'm not judging because I do
what are you talking about I really like
the direction he went with Prometheus I
just wish he had wouldn't have backed
off on it a little bit alien I like both
of those movies but yeah I can see what
you're saying I wish he would have like
opened up the mythology and gone more
like a weird right re direction [ __ ] has
leaked about what the original script
for Prometheus was and the backstory
behind the engineers and it was really
[ __ ] cool it was really cool but the
studio's didn't want to do it because it
would it included basically Christianity
and Jesus and souls and who made mankind
and we went into like basically the
Anunnaki and narubu and all that it's
basically what it was about that Jesus
was Jesus was a in the story of you were
gonna find out that that the engineers
made Jesus yeah and other spiritual
teachers to try to tame man but then
they decided they had a white man out
reboot the D [ __ ] up they were too
violent they were sinful you know I mean
and then yeah and then like you're
supposed to find out what was what was
written on the walls inside the damn
alien ship David could see it it was
outside the visible spectrum of a human
being but he could see like holographic
imagery over stuff explaining things and
instructions and stuff so that was
explains why he was doing what he was
doing and who the engineers were and
what was wrong with them they could
service some [ __ ] wrong with him - they
couldn't reproduce anymore they decided
to transcend gender so they didn't have
any females
their species but they could live for
hundreds of thousands of years and but
they were still dying off so they had to
try to they tried to reboot their
species into a male and female form so
they could reproduce yeah and remember
how they were in there and they had that
alien look like a statue of an alien
upon upon the wall and it yeah there was
what what the story was gonna be is that
sometime in the engineers past an alien
impregnated an engineer and what popped
out was that thing on the wall they got
at the deacon and it could speak and it
was like their spiritual leader well the
blood from that Deacon could be
engineered and mixed in with other
things and it would create life so they
were trying to recreate themselves with
the blood of that thing and and all this
symbolism about you know the blood of
the Savior and all this kind of [ __ ] was
all coming from teachings that the
engineers were trying to pass on to
mankind that's a so the bug of the
mythology we were taught was true yes
earnest and that's what they're trying
to that's what the story was but a
studio is like oh now we can't have that
you know I guess they thought it would
turn off the audience but I think that's
the direction that's maybe I thought
that I thought that was like a really
intriguing idea the idea was like daily
in covenant but it did seem like a more
just kind of like a formulaic yeah kinda
it was alright but it didn't really have
all the interesting ideas originally the
original meaning and what house story
was gonna go was is that the horror and
the whole thing was is that your
religions that you don't believe in
anymore like Christianity where we're
actually true
but they weren't true in the way that
you thought they just got a little lost
in from aliens yeah that's pretty cool
which I guess that's not like a totally
off-the-wall idea because they were
going on about that like back in the 70s
the [ __ ] erich von daniken Ashley's
talking chery chery got all that
Chariots of the Gods and then in narubu
and all that [ __ ] you know that's that's
which is a great I don't believe any of
that shit's true but it's a great idea
like it's a great basis for a story or
like a mythology and I kind of
yeah I kind of do wish thing he had kept
going in that direction they may go back
to that I don't know yeah you don't
think that I mean why Ridley Scott could
really tell that story I think well yeah
and they [ __ ] up for me this they cut
out some of the best scenes yeah you can
only get it on the blu-ray you know but
the engineer speaking and what it said
and everything you know and had they had
they left that scene in I think people
really would have liked that movie a lot
better yeah it explained a lot more well
I in a lot of cases and I might have
said this when we were reviewed and we
reviewed it a long time ago but in most
cases I'm a fan of like you know
judicious editing and it's like you
don't want to like over explain
everything to your audience and like you
know talk down to them or like like you
think they're stupid or something but in
Prometheus's case I think it was I think
they cut too much out yeah they were
stupid to cut that out so they left some
stuff really like ambiguous or confusing
when it didn't have to be because they
shot scenes explaining it but they took
them out because they were trying to be
more esoteric I guess item I think they
were just afraid of the whole space
Jesus concept yeah yeah they didn't want
religion to be in it but the whole thing
or they thought that people would get
offended here we go that's dumb you know
or let's not talk about religion that
yeah you think that's what they were
thinking but no they should have left
that in there it was like a religious
horror movie yeah yeah I thought was
cool and and I kind of like this because
I was man I tried to analyze that [ __ ]
for [ __ ] years what the [ __ ] did that
mean I know I said doesn't want yeah for
like two years after that movie came out
it's like you talked about it all yeah
trying to figure out what that was I
figure it all I came pretty close yeah
on some especially when I got the
blu-ray and you know the extra stuff of
what the Haley there's so much stuff
that they cut out of yeah yeah and they
cut a lot of stuff out of Blade Runner
yeah that was supposed to be in there
that's why Harrison Ford didn't like the
movie yeah there's all the cool [ __ ] got
cut out about the fact that Tyrell was
it was a replica and the real one was
down the bottom and cried in stasis yeah
and you could talk to him I was in
cryostasis just like they could you
could talk to them and you know you
could talk to somebody who was in
cryogenic storage and
and Prometheus yeah you know they were
talking to [ __ ] Weyland down in there
I thought I just just I like witness
Scott's version of the future it's
[ __ ] weird weird and probably you
know probably how it's gonna go the
nation states falling away and nothing
but corporations were you know
corporations run everything
yeah like corporate yeah it's like it's
like we call it's like corporate
corporate feudalism and we're just
[ __ ] serfs you know and they own the
legal system so they'd go to other
planets they don't have to apply any
laws they'll kill you on other planets
and [ __ ]
yeah so they can get patents on things
like get a patent on how to recreate
life and then replacing human beings
with replicants or robots because
they're better there yeah because humans
are such because she was a [ __ ] yeah
that's and we thought that's how they
think yeah that's how they think they're
like a [ __ ] down obsolete [ __ ] farm
workers and obsolete factory equipment
you know it's all these who are we made
them
that's what how corporate [ __ ]
[ __ ] me trillionaires think yeah yes
they exist only because we allow them to
exist that's how they think man yeah
yeah speaking of cool movies we saw a
really kick-ass one less I can't believe
I didn't see this ad when it came out
now Sophie sent us a couple of movies
yeah they're only just now getting read
watching them because watch one on this
we watch one last night it's called the
nice guys
it came out in 2016 I remember seeing a
couple of trailers for it back then like
we was that was before we had a MCA list
and all that stuff so this must have
been we must have gone to see some other
movie and I remember maybe it was but I
remember seeing the trailer for it but I
just never watched it and I feel like it
it did okay at the box-office I don't
think it made twice its money back it
made more than its budget but this was
it was directed by Shane Black the guy
that did lethal weapon lethal weapon 2
he was also in predator he's actually
also and I believe he wrote this as well
I think he did the new predator 2 yeah
she I think he might have
I'm not really sure yeah he he did like
a bunch of action movies in the 80s and
I still like the longest long kiss
goodnight and like a bunch of other ones
too but um yeah this movie was real I
loved this kick-ass movie it was really
really good there's a detective flick
about a detective who teams up with
basically a torpedo alright guy who
breaks other people's [ __ ] hi he's not
really an assassin but you could hire
him to beat he's like a hired thug ya
break people's legs and [ __ ] and they
get involved in this investigation
having to do it as a senator and a porn
star she was the head of the Department
of Justice that seduced him basing her
laid her it said in the 70s yeah in LA
most of it and haven't grown up there I
can verify that this movie is true
that's exactly the way it was in the 70s
I was a kid and it's weird because they
didn't shoot a lot of it in LA they
couldn't um they shot a lot of it in
Georgia and like had to build like sets
and [ __ ] like that but some of it was
shot now they were driving around and I
was recognizing signs for my childhood
like the sign and like certain as I
remember that sign it's probably gone by
now because la doesn't look like that
anymore I've been there forever now
looking at the Google Earth it doesn't
look anything like it
like it used to but yes if you like once
upon a time in Hollywood you'd like this
movie yeah and this actually goes to the
same chick the same actress isn't at
Margaret quali the one that played the
hippie girl in once upon a time in
Hollywood she's in this too yeah playing
like the girl that they're all trying to
find I have to say one of the best
things about this one I love the setting
I love the costumes you know I love how
[ __ ] balls to the wall like the
violence is very really really violent
you know what I mean but funny like
Jenna I get a funny way like it's a dark
comedy essentially by June if once upon
a time in Hollywood was a detective
flick they had a bunch of comedy in it
and it was set in the 70s remember I was
telling on the main show we know maybe
people didn't believe me but back in the
70s my in my aunt
he said they used to take me and my
cousin my ass we'd go up to [ __ ]
Yosemite
out in the [ __ ] redwood forest and
[ __ ] Camp Crystal Lake type settings and
you know I'd be walking I was like
[ __ ] ten year old kid and they're
just bunch of naked girl
I walk around corner there were [ __ ]
skinny-dipping in [ __ ] nude
sunbathing that's the way the [ __ ]
seventies were was [ __ ] bizarre well
I think they show that good movies
really captured that like with you know
thirteen-year-old girl like a porn party
she didn't think thing of it is just
like it's just like a funny they really
captured the tone but I was saying like
the best thing about this and he would
have [ __ ] thought the two main
characters played by Ryan Gosling and
[ __ ] uh what's his [ __ ] name oh
yeah Russell Crowe yeah the two of them
are hilarious together like they just
have like this great like not into zany
wacky this is kind of like a Coen
Brothers type humor like if you really
like Coen Brothers movies you will
probably really dig this if you haven't
seen it but there's gonna be a sequel to
this too evidently well he was he wanted
to make a sequel and it's actually the
end of it is kind of set up like they
resolve this case but it's like Oh
it sets up like it's gonna be like a
continuing thing he's like well he's not
sure that it made enough money oka to do
a sequel although he really does want to
do one and apparently he's written one
like I said it didn't it didn't lose
money I don't think but it didn't make
as much as they were projecting put so
much money in these things they all want
him to make a bit actually cost that
much to make I feel like you know
relatively I think this was fairly small
but I think it was only like maybe ten
that's not that much that's what I mean
that's it was only maybe fifteen million
would think that it would make enough
money over time
with blu-ray sales yeah but yeah it's
like I had kind of forgot about it I saw
a trailers for it back in the day
somebody came out four years ago and now
I'm like really glad that Sophie said it
but I mean she said it she's like this
is a [ __ ] hilarious movie you guys
you know and yeah it was I I ended up
loving it it's really really funny like
I said if you it's a good movie it's a
period piece it's kind of like a
detective hard-boiled detective yeah
like a noir kinda yeah but it was funny
yeah at times but not zany it's just
that the dudes are [ __ ] funny yeah
it's like it's like a black comedy
fellas tight funny yeah from the moves
good
like that but it's detectives and it's
kind of kind of funny too because like
these two guys are like complete
fuck-ups yeah but somehow they managed
to muddle yeah I would say the town is
man it's like I said it's like very much
like a Coen Brothers movie it reminded
me of like an old Coen Brothers not well
Blood Simple was a little bit more
serious but it reminded me of like
raising Arizona a little bit or
something like that for me kind of like
mixing Lethal Weapon in with Beverly
Hills cops but it's a detective movie
that's back in the seventies kind of
like that this is kind of like what bad
times at the El Royale was trying to do
yeah but not quite as successfully
although I liked that movie too but I
liked this one a lot better yeah but
yeah definitely check this one out this
is one that totally flew under my radar
yeah that came out four years everything
else we got Toma
I don't think so that's probably about
it so that'll wrap up our little Monday
updated well we'll see you guys later
yeah we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow